[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this is cs50 and today we
transition from the world of see and
with it pointers and some of the
struggles that you might have felt over
the past few weeks to a more familiar
world that of web programming I'm using
web browsers and mobile devices and
laptops and desktops and creating more
graphical and more interactive
experience than our traditional command
line terminals have allowed and we'll
see though along the way that a lot of
the ideas that we've been exploring over
the past few weeks are still going to
remain with us and we're gonna see them
in different ways we're gonna see them
in the form of other languages and other
syntax but the ideas will remain quite
reminiscent of what we did back in week
zero so tcp/ip is perhaps the most
technical way in the most low-level way
we can quickly make the web
uninteresting but you've probably at
least seen this acronym somewhere maybe
on your Mac your PC some setting maybe
once upon a time and this actually just
refers to a protocol or really a pair of
protocols languages of sorts that
computers speak in order to transmit
information from one computer to another
and this is what makes most of the
internet today work the fact that you
can poke your laptop and desktop and
talk to any computer on the Internet is
because of these protocols conventions
that humans decided shall exist some
years ago and they just dictate how
computers inter communicate but let's
make it a lot more familiar um in our
human worlds you've probably at some
point were sent or received a letter
these days it's perhaps more electronic
but at least you've gotten one such
letter from probably a human maybe a
grandparent or the like or sent
something yourself but before you can
actually send that message to the
recipient and put it through the u.s.
mail or the international mail service
is what needs to go on the envelope yes
or some kind of address and what is an
address consists of name where they are
okay okay so where they are might
include like a street address and like a
city a state a zip code in the US or
postal code more generally and the
country if you really want to be
specific and so all of that goes on the
front of the envelope generally in the
center of the envelope and then what
often goes on the top left-hand corner
in most countries yeah so the return
address so that if something goes wrong
I'll bid and frequently that letter can
get make its way back to you and also
the recipient knows just immediately who
actually sent them the note so that is
enough information to get a letter from
point A to point B because these
addresses these postal addresses in our
human world uniquely identify houses or
buildings or people in some sense in the
world so right now we're at 45 Quincy
Street Cambridge Massachusetts 0 to 138
USA that is probably enough specificity
for anyone in the world to mail us a
postcard saying hello world in written
form and get it to this building
meanwhile if we wanted to send something
to like the Science Center one Oxford
Street Cambridge Mass Oh to 138 USA
that's its unique address so it stands
to reason that computers including our
own Macs and PCs and Android phones and
iPhones and the like all have unique
addresses as well because after all they
want to communicate and they need to get
bits zeros and ones from point A to
point B but they're not quite as verbose
as those kinds of addresses computers
have what you probably know as IP
addresses Internet Protocol addresses
and this just means that humans decided
years ago that every computer in the
internet is gonna have a unique number
identifying it and that number is
generally of the form something dot
something dot something dot something
and as it turns out each of these some
things between the the dots is a number
from 0 to 255 and now after all these
weeks of cs50 your mind can probably
jump to a quick answer how many bits
must each of these numbers be taking up
if the range is from 0 to 255 8 so 8 and
why is that 8 so 2 is 256 has been a
recurring theme and if you don't recall
that's fine but yes this is 8 bits 8
bits 8 bits 8 bits which means the
numbers that we humans use to uniquely
identify our computers on the internet
or 32 bits in total well there's
probably a number another number that
can roughly come to mind if you've got
32 bits how high can you count roughly
speaking from 0 - like I heard a murmur
4 billion so it's roughly 4 billion and
we brought that up in week 0 with like a
4 billion page phonebook
imagining that so four billion is
roughly what you can count up to with 32
bits so that means there can be four
billion computers devices or anything on
the internet uniquely identified small
white lie because that's actually not
quite enough these days with all the
devices and all the humans in the world
but we found workarounds for that
question
but only half of them at the time know
so yes if by 2023 or whatever your
humans are projected to be almost
entirely online and there's some
billions and billions of people eight
billion or so then that's a problem for
this system thankfully as long ago as
twenty years ago do people realize
mathematically this is going to be a
problem and so there's actually a newer
version of IP Internet Protocol this is
version four we're talking about which
is still pretty omnipresent in the world
version six actually uses not 32 bits
but 128 bits which is massive and I
can't even pronounce how big of a number
that is so we're thinking about it and
the biggest companies of the world have
already transitioned to using bigger
addresses rather than these 32-bit
addresses but these are still pretty
common on almost any device you might
own or see on campus or elsewhere so if
you have a unique address that's enough
to put on the front of the envelope and
it turns out that if you're sending an
email or chat message or whatever you to
your Mac PC your phone has an IP address
so that's enough to put in the top left
hand corner conceptually but you need
one more piece of information it turns
out that on the internet there are
servers computers that are just
constantly listening for people to
connect to them like us checking our
email and visiting Facebook and Gmail
and other such web sites and those
servers that can do multiple things
right Google has lots of businesses they
give you email and web services and
videoconferencing and lots of other
internet-based services and so humans
also decided years ago to identify all
of these possible internet services with
just unique numbers names also but also
unique numbers and it turns out that
that humans decided years ago that when
you visit a web site there's one more
piece of information that's got to go on
this envelope
not just the server's IP address that
you're trying to connect to but also the
number 80 because 80 equals HTTP acronym
you're surely familiar with by now
and that just denotes this is a web
request if instead it said something
like 25 that's SMTP which is email so
that might mean inside of this virtual
envelope is actually an email message
going to Gmail or the like and there's
bunches more numbers but the point is
that there are numbers that uniquely
identify so when Google gets a a virtual
envelope just a whole bunch of bits
zeros and ones that in some way
has an IP address on it as the
destination it also knows always this an
email or is this a videoconference
message or is this a chat message or
something else so just to make this more
real then if I'm going to go ahead and
write this down my IP address to whom
I'm sending something might be 1.2.3.4
generally then I'm gonna send it to say
port 80
maybe my IP address is 5.6 dot 7.8 and
so an envelope I'll be a port leaver and
it's really just gonna have those pieces
of information the destination address
colon and then the number of the service
you care about HTTP or whatever and then
your own IP address and more information
but the point is both sender and
recipient undresses that's enough to get
data from one computer in the world to
another and there's so much more
complexity this is a whole field in
computer science of networking if you
like this kind of stuff but that's how
in a nutshell the internet gets data
from point A to point B and this
envelope just represents a whole bunch
of zeros and ones but what's inside of
that envelope and that's where we'll
focus today and in the weeks to come
it's actually content like it's the
email you care about or the webpage you
care about and how do we actually decide
what server we're connecting to well
typically you might go to a so called
URL Uniform Resource locator URL is just
the address of a server and that's gonna
be the really the ultimate recipient of
that envelope that we're trying to send
but this of course is not an IP address
this does not follow the pattern
something that's something that's
something dot something so if all of us
humans are constantly typing stuff like
this into our browsers yet the whole
story I just told is about numbers and
port numbers and low-level stuff
where's the connection does anyone
already know how you get from typing
this to a bunch of zeros and ones that
are somehow addressed with numbers DNS I
heard what's DNS yeah so it turns out
there's a there's a technology in the
world domain name system in fact and DNS
domain name system is just a type of
service on the internet that Harvard
maintains and Yale maintains and Comcast
and Verizon and a lot of the big players
in the world whose purpose in life is to
run servers that convert what are called
domain names
but two IP addresses and vice-versa so
that when we humans type in WWE ample
calm into a browser it's our Mac or PC
or phone that contacts a local server a
DNS server on the local campus or
university or apartment or whatever asks
what is the IP address for WWE exsample
comm and then what your Mac or PC or
phone does is it writes that address on
the envelope but it puts a request for
specific web page inside of the envelope
and when you get back a response from
that server it's gonna be your address
that's on the front of the envelope and
inside of the envelope is going to be
the webpage or the email or the chat
message or whatever it is you were
trying to actually access so let's tease
this apart into some of its components
first of all this thing here highlighted
in yellow is officially the domain name
and you probably all use this term
before it's usually something dot
something com typically refers to
commerce or commercial although anyone
for any purpose can use com back in the
day very popular word ComNet or GDU gov
mil and these were all very us centric
because it tended to be the United
States that really kicked off this use
of the internet and DNS but now it's
certainly spread globally and so there's
hundreds now of what are called TLDs
top-level domains they tend to be three
or more characters if they denote a word
and they tend to be two characters if
they denote a country like u.s. is
United States JP is Japan UK United
Kingdom and so forth those are just
country codes that do the same thing but
what's this at the front world wide web
or WWE or more generally is an example
of what technically speaking what is
this
what does this mean yeah it's a
sub-domain it's one way of thinking
about it in fact of all of you many of
you here probably have email addresses
of the forum college at Harvard edu or G
Harvard edu or the like
those are subdomains Harvard such a big
place that they actually put everyone in
different categories of domains
otherwise known as subdomains and that
might be a word or phrase that comes
before the domain name here but it can
also just mean the name of a server so
if example.com is the company or
business whose website you're trying to
visit their domain is example.com and
they bought that domain name some years
ago and they spent a few dollars every
year probably renewing the fee for that
and they have at least one server whose
name is www and that exists within their
domain they might have dozens or
hundreds or just one server each of them
can have a name so this is generally
called the host name so when it's an
email address it often implies a sub
domain like a category of addresses but
when it's in a URL like this it means
probably a specific machine or specific
set of machines conventionally the web
servers that the company runs doesn't
have to be called WW for historical
purposes and my team tends to use web
mit.edu but almost everyone else in the
world uses WW or nothing at all it's not
required you can actually just visit
many websites without visiting any host
name and it just works as well thanks to
DNS giving you the IP address but what
about the file you're actually
requesting like what does it actually
mean to visit this URL one on many
servers this implicitly means hey web
server
give me a file just a text file called
index.html that's the name of the file a
text file that you could create with
cs50 IDE or even notepad or TextEdit on
your own Mac or PC that contains a
language called HTML and we'll take a
look at that language in just a bit and
some of you might have seen it before
but the language in which web pages are
written is HTML and we'll give you the
building blocks conceptually and
practically for that today you'll use it
over the coming weeks in many different
contexts but we'll use it ultimately to
create the contents of websites but
today we'll focus first on this HTTP
anyone know what that stands for yeah
yeah hypertext Transfer Protocol and and
honestly in most of technology it's not
so much what the acronyms represent
that's all that important but really
what the technology does and in this
case hypertext Transfer Protocol will
see hypertext in a moment that's a
another way of saying HTML Transfer
Protocol p4 protocol that's another
buzzword so protocols are not
programming languages per se they are
conventions and we humans have
conventions too for instance if I were
to meet someone for the first time I
probably wouldn't stand on stage and
lean down like this to do it but I might
say hi I'm David Stephan nice to meet
you and we have this weird handshake
that was aborted prematurely there that
we had this weird convention was humans
at least in the US of like greeting
someone with a handshake and Stefan just
knew to do that however awkwardly and
then he disengaged because the sort of
transaction was complete and that's not
unlike what a web server does when you
request a web page you're sending a
request to someone as though you're
extending your hand you're expecting
something in return but in the case of a
computer of course it's like the web
page itself coming back in an envelope
from point B to point a so that's what a
protocol is we just have been programmed
to know what to do when we want to
request a greeting or information and
get something back in return it's like a
client-server relationship in a
restaurant a customer requests something
off the menu the server the waiter or
waitress brings it to them and thus
completes that transaction as well and
that's what the internet is to clients
and servers browsers and servers
computers and other computers ultimately
so with that relationship in mind let's
take a look at what's actually inside of
this envelope in the case of Stefan's
and my greeting it was more visual but
in the case of computer it's going to be
more textual literally so inside of the
envelope the virtual envelope set so to
speak that your browser sends to a
server when trying to request a web page
is actually a message that looks like
this thankfully it's not terribly
cryptic although the dot dot dot implies
there's more contents inside of the
envelope but the key word here literally
is get a verb and there's other verbs
that the browser can use and this one
literally means get me the following
home page what home page do you want to
get well the default one this forward
slash as it's called just represents the
default web of a page on a website and
in many cases that
bliss Utley means an actual file called
index.html just a convention it can be
called other things and not exist at all
but in many cases that means implicitly
get me a file called index.html and
we'll see what that looks like in a
moment HTTP slash 1.1 just means hey
Stefan I speak HTTP version 1.1
hopefully you do as well there can be
other a newer and older versions of the
same thing notice down here though
whoops notice now here though that the
hostname is also in this envelope
because it turns out that web servers
can do multiple things at once and they
can serve multiple domains you don't
need a your own personal unique server
to serve a website you can have tens
hundreds thousands of different websites
all on the same server and if any of you
ever have paid for your own domain name
or your own personal home page or the
like you are probably paying someone for
shared space on one server or more
servers not for your own personal
dedicated one but again this might
implicitly mean the same thing is this
give me index.html so what is it that
actually comes back from the server the
server hopefully responds with a message
that looks like this it responds with
confirmation of the version of the
protocol it speaks that's like Stephan
saying yes I speak HTTP 1.1 as well 200
is a numeric code that signifies
literally okay
all as well I understood you here's the
information you requested and content
type below it is a more technical way of
saying the type of content I'm handing
back to you in my own envelope from
point B to point a or from Stephan to me
is in a language called HTML that
happens to be text why does it look like
this humans years ago just decided that
this would be the sequence of characters
the computers literally send to
communicate that information so let's
actually try this in one case maybe for
instance with harvard.edu and see what
actually happens to see what else we
might see so let me go ahead and open up
Chrome or any browser for that matter
that supports some kind of debugging and
diagnostics and I'm going to do this and
you can access this in different places
I'm going to go up to view developer and
view developer tools this is something
that comes with chrome you sometimes
have to enable it in Safari and other
browsers but almost every browser these
days has this capability and you'll know
that this just opened up a whole bunch
of tabs at the bottom of my screen here
that I'm gonna be able to use to
actually explore what is did I kick
something else apologies
its back okay won't step on neck so what
is this gonna allow us to do well notice
there's a lot of features here it's
overwhelming at first glance but there's
a tab here called network and it turns
out that one of the features chrome
gives to developers which you now all
are as software developers is the
ability to see what's going on
underneath the hood of a browser to see
what is inside of these sort of virtual
envelopes that your browser has all the
users been sending from itself to all
servers elsewhere so I'm going to go
ahead and do this I'm gonna go ahead and
actually visit HTTP colon slash slash
harvard.edu and hit enter and you'll see
a whole bunch of stuff happens including
the web page appearing at the top of the
screen I'm gonna ignore all of this
stuff at the bottom except for the very
very first request if i zoom in on this
notice that highlighted in blue here is
the very first request Harvard edu and
if I click on that I'm gonna see a
little more information at left all
right right and if I go scroll down to
what are called request headers the
lines of text that were inside the
message that my browser sent this is
literally what my browser sent inside
the envelope unbeknownst to me when I
visited harvard.edu thankfully it
confirms my prediction earlier yet slash
HTTP 1.1 because I requested to Harvard
dot you to use homepage host is
harvard.edu then there's the dot dot dot
the stuff that we don't particularly
care about today but let me go ahead and
look at the response so this was my
request this was my hand going out to
Stefan let's see what his or the
server's response is by scrolling up to
this which is called response headers
huh
Harvard server fortunately does speak
the same protocol as me 1.1 of HTTP but
apparently Harvard moved permanently
what does that mean I went to HTTP colon
slash slash harvard.edu not there where
is it well there's a little more
information here there's a lot of dot
dot dot things we don't care about
but if you focus on one that o location
where is Harvard now apparently yeah say
yeah it looks like Harvard moved
permanently from HTTP colon slash slash
Harvard edu to and let me highlight it
HTTP colon slash slash wwr beauty with
two notable changes one there's the www
and two there's also what that might
catch your eye s which most of you
probably know these days means secure
which implies encryption in the spirit
of Caesar in Visionnaire but much more
secure than those simple ciphers the
information is somehow scrambled now
when I'm communicating between myself
and Harvard edu so there's two decisions
there Harvard has decided that they want
to allow and indeed require users to
visit their websites securely so that no
one no company no government no family
members can necessarily see what is
being requested of Harvard's web site
because that is scrambled information
much like using something like Caesar or
Visionnaire and Harvard also probably
for branding reasons but also partly for
technical reasons decided we want you to
think of our website as WWE Harbor edu
and it's a mix of marketing and
technical for a few different reasons
one of which is WWE humans just all know
means website and if you see Harvard edu
this is less true these days might not
necessarily imply as obviously that this
is a website's URL frankly not too many
years ago even advertisements and TV ads
and printed ads and the like would even
show HTTP colon slash slash to really
make clear to viewers that this is a web
address but gradually is more and more
people get on the internet and
understand technology and URLs and the
like we can just start dropping the
stuff that is unnecessary clutter
because all of us now know intuitively a
Harvard that you do it's probably a web
address that I can just type into a
browser and the browser or the server
will finish my thought for me and
actually prepend the secure URL or the
dub-dub-dub or the like alright so we
still haven't actually found Harvard it
seems so let's do this instead let me go
ahead and zoom out and visit a different
URL let me go ahead and again go to view
developer developer tools network tab
and now let me visit that more verbose
URL more precise URL and hit enter again
a whole bunch of stuff gets requested
more on that some other time but now if
I click on the first such request and
look at my response headers you'll
actually see albeit in a different
format now that the status of this
request is 200 which recall meant okay
okay so now these are two numbers that
honestly you probably not really seen or
cared all that much about 200 and 301
but odds are you've seen at least one
other number when visiting URLs for
instance besides actually seeing 200 and
301 you've probably seen 404 now it
apparently refers to not found but more
in real terms what does that mean how do
you induce that error the site doesn't
exist you mistyped a URL the web page
doesn't exist the system administrator
just changed the name on something or
it's an old URL like any number of
reasons can mean that the file was not
found that file might have been
index.html or any other URL but all this
time when you visited a website and
you've seen 404 it's not clear frankly
why servers have been bothering to tell
us 404 most people don't need that level
of information but it derives from that
HTTP response that first line of text
inside the envelope coming back from
Stefan or the web server more generally
that says 404 not found and that means
the user probably did something wrong or
if the data has simply disappeared from
the server and there's so many more of
these things as well and in fact you
might get responses like we just did
from Harvard supporting not just one
point one but version two of HTTP so
just realize if you tinker with your own
Mac or PC the messages might look a
little different based on your browser
and the website and that's just because
things are evolving over time and
versions are changing but there's so
many others of these and this is just a
short abbreviated list 200 and 301 we
saw 404 you yourselves have probably
seen 401 and 403 generally referred to
you haven't logged in or you're just not
authorized to access information because
it doesn't belong to you for instance
500 you're all going to experience
before long that 500 is in
server error which is not so much the
server's error as like your fault and my
fault when we've written buggy code so
in the weeks to come not this week but
when we start writing Python code and
sequel to talk to databases we're all
gonna screw up at some point and a
browser will often see a 500 error from
a server if indeed there's a problem
with code 418 doesn't actually exist
this was a April Fool's joke I think in
like 1988 where some people with a lot
of free time wrote up a whole formal
specification for an HTTP status code of
418 I am a teapot and it still kind of
exists in lower internet lower so those
are just some of the numbers you might
see but they're not all that technical
if you just know where to look for them
and you know as a developer now what
they signify for you yeah ah good
question what's the difference between
200 ok and 302 found so 302 if you read
into the documentation would actually
tell you that this also induces a
redirect whereby just like 301 when the
browser gets a 301 or a 302
the browser should be redirected to the
new URL that we saw in the header so to
speak called location : whatever it was
the difference is that move permanently
means that the browser should remember
that this redirection is happening and
stop bothering the server with the same
original questions remember what the new
URL is 302 means found it but don't rely
on this keep asking me again and again
so it's just a performance optimization
so you don't annoy the server
unnecessarily in the case of 301 which
just cost time and money in some sense
all right so you might have heard about
this before can only kind of get away
with this in Cambridge not so much New
Haven has anyone ever visited safety
school org you're welcome to on your
laptop or your phone so some very clever
Harvard students I think years ago
bought this domain frankly they probably
been paying like 10 or more dollars per
year ever since just to keep this joke
alive but it's wonderfully illustrative
because if we go back to Chrome or any
browser and let me go ahead and open up
a browser tab and go to safety
school.org enter Oh interesting where
did I get redirected
Hey okay so the more interesting
question for us is how are they doing
that well let me go back into the IDE
for actually let me go into my browser
and open up a new tab view developer
developer tools look at the network tab
and now let me go ahead whoops let me go
ahead and visit HTTP colon slash slash
safety school org enter scroll back up
to the top where I see the first request
and you can see more technically if this
kind of doesn't take the fun out of the
joke
all these Harvard students did years ago
was configure this domain name to return
a 301 moved permanently to Yale
University now it's only fair especially
since the yo students are watching this
live right now from New Haven let's take
a look at one other site called Harvard
sucks org so this domain too does exist
let me clear that screen and go to HTTP
colon slash slash Harvard sucks dot org
enter and this is an actual web site so
not only did these enterprise and Yale
students buy the domain name they've
also been hosting the web site for years
since there's a wonderful YouTube video
there that actually speaks to a very fun
hack that they did some years ago at
Harvard Yale the football game but you
can see here oh that alright so there's
a minor one so Harvard sucks org
actually now lives at wwr Burt sucks or
but then you actually stay there and so
I encourage you to go to this site as
well as the other for all your Harvard
and Yale shopping needs
so that is HTTP HTTP is the protocol the
set of conventions that browsers use
when talking to web servers and it's the
protocol that governs how those web
servers respond to the browsers we've
quantized this in the form of these
virtual envelopes which is just a sort
of physical incarnation of zeros and
ones that are technically going back and
forth across the internet but it's
embodied in my handshake with Stefan
what's really happening I initiate he
responds and it's like a client-server
type relationship so how do you actually
now do creative work how do you make
Gail edu how do you make Harvard sucks
org how do you make cs50 zone website or
Google or Facebook well what really
matters now what's is what's deeper
inside of that envelope
addition to these headers this textual
information like 200 ok or 301 moved
permanently there's another language
baked embedded inside of that envelope
deeper down called HTML hypertext markup
language this is the language which is
also text in which web pages are written
and so if you've ever visited a website
on the internet and I just noticed that
Aaron is doing that on repeat doesn't
see what you're looking at is a browsers
rendering of HTML so hTML is just text
and we're gonna see it in a moment the
browser reads that text top to bottom
left to right much like clang reads your
Seco top to bottom left to right but
rather than convert your text to zeros
and ones what a browser does is
interpret it line by line by line and it
does what you say so if you say hey
browser put Aaron's photo on the screen
it is going to do that if you say hey
browser write the words a staff in big
black text the browser is gonna do that
if you tell the browser to layout a
whole menu it's gonna do that and we'll
see in just a moment how you convey
those terms hTML is not a programming
language it is indeed a markup language
which means it just lays things out
structurally and aesthetically so the
website here that we're looking at has a
bunch of images all of which are what
are called animated gifs which are very
much in vogue these days unlike Reddit
and phones and iMessage and the like but
those are just images files that are
actually being transferred from cs50
server to your browser and but if I go
up to view developer and now view source
and you can could have been doing this
all these years you can actually see the
so-called HTML that drives cs50 s
website so this is all the HTML and I'm
deliberately scrolling fast through it
that implements that cs50 staff page and
if we scroll all the way to the bottom
you'll see that 1008 lines later is the
web page done but it's just text and in
fact let me scroll back up to the top
and just point out a few salient details
you'll see familiar patterns and the
examples we're about to start looking at
the very first line probably is that
doctype HTML which is like a little hint
to the browser that says quite
explicitly hey browser the document type
you're about to see is indeed HTML but
the rest of the web page follows a
structural pattern
you'll see that it's already kind of
nicely indented even though some of
these lines are a little long and are
wrapping but you'll see this convention
in open bracket which is an angled
bracket like a less than sign the key
word HTML maybe some pattern like this
Lang equals en-us that sounds like
language aus English maybe more on that
in a bit
and then this closed bracket or a
greater than side sign that kind of
completes the thought then inside of
that HTML tag so to speak indented
beneath it is this the head of the
webpage the head of the webpage is
something that you mostly can't see it
generally refers to the tab at the top
of the page and just invisible
information and if I scroll down further
we'll see really the guts of the web
page which are in the whole so called
body of the web page so these things
that I've just been highlighting albeit
in a very big context of a big wet
thousand line web page are just called
HTML tags HTML is a tag based language a
markup based language where you just say
what you want to appear where you want
to appear where you want it to appear so
what does that actually mean well let's
take a look at a simpler example in the
form of this slide which is perhaps the
simplest web page that you can make this
one here this is perhaps the simplest
correct syntactically correct web page
you can write that saying hey browser
the type of document is HTML hey browser
here's the start of my HTML page hey
browser here's the head of my web page
hey browser here comes the title of my
web page hey browser the title of this
page shall be for the sake of discussion
hello title but you could say literally
anything there that you want but now
thanks get interesting and some of you
have certainly seen HTML before and some
of you haven't but you can probably just
infer even if you haven't seen HTML what
this tag is doing because it looks the
same but yet a little different so if
this is saying hey browser here comes
the title what is this probably saying
intuitively yeah that's it for the title
like hey browser that's it for the title
so you might call this a start tag and
this an end tag or an open tag and a
close tag think about it however you
want but in HTML there's generally this
nice symmetry once you start something
you eventually finish it and you do it
in the right order so you do you start
tags in one order and then you close
them in reverse order so that everything
is nicely symmetric and indeed the
indentation just like
see technically doesn't matter at all
you could have a really really ugly
webpage with no white spaces whatsoever
it would still work fine for the browser
because it doesn't care just much harder
for our humans to read so this
convention is to indent just like in C
just so it's more clear what the
hierarchy or the nesting is so to speak
this line here means hey browser that's
it for the head it's another close tag
hey browser here comes the body of the
page so much like head here body here
most of the pages content is indeed in
the body of the web page that's what you
the humans actually see and mostly in
the head we'll just see things like the
title and just a couple of other things
in a little bit the message inside this
web page is apparently hello body then
close body close HTML and that's it so
when I said earlier that inside of these
envelopes is just a whole bunch of text
all I meant was this this is what's
inside of this envelope just below the
protocol information the HTTP
information that just said 200 okay or
any of those other messages so when the
browser receives this envelope it opens
it up it reads it top to bottom left to
right and then it literally interprets
that file top to bottom doing exactly
what you tell it to do so how do we go
about actually doing this you can write
HTML on any text program you can write
it in TextEdit on a Mac on notepad on PC
you can technically use Microsoft Word
or Google Docs but that's out of context
and bad like those gives you features
you don't want but you generally want a
text editor and we of course have a text
editor in cs50 IDE so let me actually go
there I'm gonna go into cs50 IDE and I'm
gonna go up to file new and I'm gonna go
and preemptively to save the file with
the only filename I remember from
earlier which was index.html just like C
programs and in files called something
dot C HTML files often end in dot HTML
sometimes dot HTM but often dot HTML so
let me go ahead and click Save there and
now I'm gonna go ahead and do week type
exactly that same code so Open bracket
exclamation points and that's the only
exclamation point we'll expect the first
line is unfortunately a little different
from all the others then I'm going to do
Open bracket HTML close bracket and
you'll notice that just like with C the
ID tries to be a little helpful and
finish your thought so it already closed
the tag for me now that's just on me to
hit enter to kind of move it in
place now I'm gonna what come came next
inside the head oh okay what came next
the head so open bracket head close
bracket inside of head was its Heidel
and then I think it just said hello
title though I could call that anything
I want then below the head but inside
the HTML tag still was my body so let me
type that here and I think I said hello
body so I boy but the bow day okay body
save alright so now I have a text file
in the IDE it seems to match up with
what we showed as a canonical you page
you are before now we need to load it in
a browser and this is a little
paradoxical because I'm obviously
writing this text in a browser and yet I
need the browser to read it so this is
just because the IDE integrated
development environment that we've been
using is itself web-based that's just
kind of an incidental at the tail the
fact that I have written this code in a
file now is what's important it could be
in the cloud as it is it could be on my
Mac it could be on my PC it could be on
any other server on the Internet
the point is I need to access this file
somehow and so it turns out that we're
not going to compile it there are no
zeros and ones involved anymore there's
no machine code we're gonna leave it
just like this HTML was interpreted
literally line by line top to bottom no
zeros and ones needed but I am gonna
need to run my own web server not the
IDE itself I want to run as the
developer my own web server what is a
web server
it's like Stefan it's just a program
kind of sitting there waiting and
waiting and waiting for something to
happen and that's something is
presumably a request from a browser at
which point it will respond with a
handshake or more specifically with this
file so how do I do this well in the IDE
we actually include a free program
called HTTP server every all of the
software in cs50 IDE is free and open
source so we've simply chosen some of
the most popular packages one of which
is called literally HTTP server and if I
go ahead and hit enter you'll see
somewhat cryptic information at first
but let's see it's starting up the HTTP
server it's serving dot slash well what
does dot mean this folder so just serve
up the contents of this current folder
that I'm in
now it's saying it's available on this
URL and this URL is gonna vary by who is
running this if you're running it you're
gonna see a different URL but what is
interesting is the number turns out that
because this is my little own personal
web server it's not using port 80 which
I claimed earlier was the default it's
using a different convention 80 80 80 80
it's just a human convention it's not
like standardized in the same way but
this way I can serve files separate from
the IDE because the IDE itself is
actually listening on port 80 or
technically 443 because it's using HTTP
and I don't want to confuse my files
with cs50 IDE zone files the actual user
interface that you're all familiar with
so just like Stefan can hear here from
say hello to multiple people and Google
servers can handle multiple services so
can my own IDE listen on multiple ports
as they're called 80 25 443 or in this
case 8080 so what does this all mean I'm
gonna go ahead and literally click on
this URL open it in another tab on my
browser and you'll see somewhat cryptic
output but this is just a succinct way
of saying here is the index the listing
of slash which is now the default area
of my web site I've got two folders
source five which is on the courses
website it's all of today's files in
case we want to look at them up without
writing them from scratch and then the
file I just created index dot HTML so if
I go ahead now and click on index.html
there we have it hello body and we don't
see the tab just because I full-screen
Chrome but if I actually remove that
full screening and zoom up to the top of
the tab you see hello title there and if
I go back into this file meanwhile and I
say hello body night nice to meet you
this one got weird now I'm gonna go
ahead and click reload and now you see
this let's go ahead and take a
five-minute break sooner rather than
later so that we can address the
projector issue we'll be right back all
right
so to recap there are more tags than
just HTML and head and title and body
there's things that give us images and
sound certainly and many many many other
things so let's take a look more
manually at just one or two other
examples and then get a sense of the
whole menu of tags that might be
available let me go ahead and create a
new file now and I'll go ahead and call
this image
dot html' in anticipation of making a
demonstration now that has an image to
save time I'm just gonna go ahead and
paste the contents of the previous file
but I'm gonna go ahead and get rid of
the body this time and start to actually
embed an image in here now in advance
I've downloaded an image of Yale's own
bulldog handsome Dan in a file called
Dan dot JPEG and I've uploaded it to the
IDE in the same folder that index dot
HTML is in and now that image dot HTML
is in and you can include an image by
using an IMG tag but you have to specify
to the browser what the image you
actually want to embed is and so to do
this as you may know you we have
attributes so just like the HTML tag as
we saw earlier and can now see in the
example here has a language attribute
specifying English as the default
language for this page to help things
like Google Translate and the like so it
is the image tag get modified by this
attribute called source
it's just SRC and IMG because those are
more succinct representations of image
and source saves us some keystrokes and
I can type in here dan dot jpg and then
just for good measure in well rather I
can then close the tag using the
corresponding angle bracket the greater
than sign but whereas all of the other
tags thus far have kind of a notion of
starting and stopping or opening and
closing the image tag doesn't because
the image is either there or it's not
there's really no conceptual notion of
starting an image and then eventually
stopping an image but let's add one
other detail turns out that there's yet
other attributes so you can have zero or
more on any tag for folks who have
trouble seeing content on webpages and
indeed rely on tools like screen readers
there's actually attributes that can
help in cases like that turns out
there's an alternative tag or alt where
you can actually say photo of handsome
Dan which is a textual description of
whatever it is you're embedding in the
web page this way someone who's not
cited but who has a screen reader that
can read that to them can actually
understand what it is that's on the web
page so most folks wouldn't see that
unless you actually hover over it or
have it spoken to you so let me go ahead
and save this file go back to the index
of the web server that I ran earlier
with HTTP server and now click on image
and voila you'll see Dan jpg embedded in
the web
Paige of course this webpage doesn't
actually do all that much yet and so
suppose we actually wanted to link to
one page or another what we can do that
as well let me go back to the IDE copy
this same code just as a starting point
create a new file called link HTML and
then in this file we'll start with the
same contents but let me get rid of that
body and simply say for instance let's
have people visit Harvard so I could say
visit HTTP s for secure wwr Bertie u
slash or maybe even without the slash it
doesn't matter for the default page
period let me save this let me go back
to the index of the web server reload so
that I can see the new file link dot
HTML that I created and now click link
HTML and while la hmm so it's a URL
visually but it's not actually clickable
but that's because the browser is only
going to do what you told it to do and
all I've implicitly told it to do is
display this black text here if I
actually want to make it interactive I
need another tag well it turns out in
HTML there's an anchor tag somewhat
cryptically names and it's also
succinctly written as a four anchor and
with the anchor tag can you anchor at
this point in the page a link or a hyper
reference as it was once called to that
specific URL so that attribute by
convention is called href hyper
reference that is the destination to
which you want to link I can now close
that tag but I now need to tell the user
where they're going so I could just say
Harvard for instance and put my period
out there save the file go back to the
tab here click reload and now you'll see
the dichotomy I'm seeing one thing
Harvard but if you hover over it and
it's super small here you can actually
see as a safety check in the bottom
left-hand corner typically the URL that
you'll actually be led to now as an
aside with this very very simple feature
of HTML you can actually socially
engineer people as is commonly done with
phishing attacks pH is H ing so you've
ever gotten some spam either in your
inbox or your spam folder odds are
someone's tried to ask you for your
username and password or for your money
or for your PayPal account PayPal is
especially a common target here but you
can see how you can very easily on four
only trick and mislead people especially
if they don't necessarily understand
some of these fundamentals let me go
back here for instance and say here well
there's nothing stopping me from doing
this little mischievous trick I can
change these HRF to Yale but the text to
Harvard thereby tricking someone haha
you're actually going to Hara Yale's
website instead but more maliciously and
in these phishing emails or spams that
you might have been getting over the
past several years you could imagine
typing anything you want here like
PayPal comm and then here could be W W
some malicious web site that wants your
money hopefully that does not exist comm
save reload the page and honestly most
people myself included are not going to
always paranoid check where I'm actually
going I'm just gonna click on a link and
voila you might not notice the URL bar
changing because you're being whisked
away to some website and honestly it's
not all that hard to recreate websites
in fact just to really hammer this point
home let me go to paypal.com and using
today's primitives notice that you can
go to view developer view source this is
the HTML implementing PayPal's website
looks good let me copy and paste that
into say a new file called paypal eight
HTML let me save that here now let me go
back to my web server reload open paypal
dot HTML and voila I have made PayPal so
it's not even that hard to mimic where
people think they are going now
intellectual property issues aside that
I just copied and pasted someone else's
website this is clearly not fully
operational because what I don't have
access to is their database and their
code on the server and all of the
intellectual property and business logic
so to speak that actually makes PayPal
what it is but HTML the point is is
purely openly accessible by anyone it's
not encrypted it's not zeros and ones
but it tends to be so aesthetic and
structural in nature that it that's not
really the juicy stuff in a business but
this technique can certainly be abused
in this way so moving forward just be
more mindful of this because most emails
you get these days buy a Gmail or any
tool are the
selves implemented in HTML even when
you're typing out a gmail message and
have never even thought about HTML that
email is actually being sent underneath
the hood as HTML why well if you've ever
used a bulleted list or a numbered list
if you've dude bold facing or italics or
any of those aesthetic features in Gmail
or other programs those are implemented
as HTML but just using nice user
friendly interfaces so you can just
click icons you don't have to think
about open brackets something close
bracket but we could do that for
instance if we go ahead and look at a
few other examples let me go ahead here
and actually go back to our very first
one index dot HTML and suppose I just
want to really draw attention to hello I
can actually use the strong tag which
implies bold typically save that let me
go back to the web server that I had
open a moment ago click on index dot
HTML after reloading it and now it's a
little subtle because it's small but you
can probably see that hello is indeed
boldface now so if you've ever clicked
the B icon in Gmail that's all it's
doing underneath the hood Gmail is
taking your word hello and secretly
putting Open bracket strong close
bracket and then the opposite the close
tag after it and that's what it's
sending to the recipient of that message
so what else can you do well let me go
ahead and do this let me go ahead and
open up say a few files that I created
in advance one is called paragraphs HTML
and let me point this out first so in
paragraphs I just have three paragraphs
of Latin text and they are rendered for
instance as follows if I go into source
5 and I go into paragraphs HTML looks
nice don't know what it says in fact
it's pretty much gibberish but it's nice
three nice paragraphs but notice how
pedantic hTML is I actually had to use
another tag to achieve those paragraphs
even if I had very reasonably written
these three paragraphs like you might in
Google Docs or Microsoft Word it's just
three paragraphs indent each hit enter
enter in between them looks good it's
wrapping because it's a really long
paragraph off to the right but that's
fine and I save this and I go to
paragraphs and reload notice that it all
bunches together intuitively why is that
happen
No what's the logic behind this bug now
I'll be in anesthetic bug yeah yeah this
those additional spaces not being
accounted for they're just being pushed
together because even though HTML does
respect one space otherwise everything
would be completely smushed it ignores
multiple spaces whether it's new lines
or tabs or multiple hits of the spacebar
and it only does ultimately what you
tell it to do so unless you explicitly
with tags in HTML say give me a new
paragraph ok that's it for this
paragraph give me a new paragraph else
that's that now that's it for the
paragraph it's just going to clump them
all together maybe separating with a
single space which is clearly not the
effect we want so just remember that
hTML is really nitpicky when it comes to
that and much like and see your code
won't compile if it's not quite right in
HTML it will display but it's not gonna
display quite right is the key there
well what are their features today's
HTML have the reality is we'll give you
a general conceptual overview of HTML
today we'll give you a taste of some of
the tags but the reality is this too is
a sort of language that you could really
learn by doing and by looking at online
references or texts that actually
summarize the various tags but let's
look at at least a few more let me go
into now heading say HTML and you'll see
this turns out that there are tags
called h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 h6 these are very
commonly used on websites that differ
have different headings like big and
bold a little smaller and ball the
little smaller in bolts to do like
chapter and section headings see a
Swifties website is very hierarchical if
you look through the syllabus you'll see
lots of different font sizes and bold
facing and the like that derives from
are using these built-in heading tags if
I go ahead and open this in my browser
we will see the effect by default h1 is
big and bold h2 is big but not as big in
bold h3 is a little smaller h4 five and
six and this follows the paradigm in
like academic papers and books that have
chapters and sections and subsections
and like you just get this feature for
free from HTML well what else is there
well if you actually have tabular data
things you want to lay out in rows and
columns well it turns out that HTML
supports tables let's glimpse at this -
and if I go into table
HTML in my browser will see this effect
it's not all that interesting I kind of
mimic the idea of a phone pad where
these numbers are lining up in columns
and in rows but invisibly this thing is
actually laid out with tags if I go to
the IDE and look down in here you'll see
some copy-paste of before HTML head and
body but then notice here hey browser
here comes a table and you see albeit
surrounded by unfamiliar tags probably
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and then the symbols down there so
let's just infer because the reality is
much of your learning of HTML and soon
another language will see it will just
be indirectly if you're curious as to
how some web page is implementing some
feature you actually look at its source
code and you refer by example how you
could do the same so take a guess if
this tag effectively says hey browser
here comes the table this tag here even
if you've never seen HTML probably means
table row hey browser here comes a row
in my table this one's less obvious but
TD T DT D stands for table data or table
cell so hey browser here comes a cell
another cell another cell three of them
in total hey browser that's it for this
row and then repeat the pattern so
here's where HTML just gets a little
mundane after a while like once you see
the name of the tag and once you know
what attributes if any it supports you
just kind of follow this pattern like
that's it for HTML there start tags
there's end tags and sometimes they're
not even end tags if they're not needed
and there's attributes and that's HTML
now if you want to be sure that your
code is correct
you have a few options let me actually
go ahead and open up for instance hello
dot HTML from earlier just so I have a
simple example or index dot HTML from
earlier let me go to validator validator
w3.org turns out there's tools out there
that will just help give you feedback on
whether or not your HTML is valid is
correct and this is useful because
sometimes it might look ok to you on
Chrome but honestly if your friend or
family member visits the exact same page
on edge or IE or Safari or Firefox might
not look the same because the companies
that make those browsers sometimes
disagree on how to render HTML and so if
it's not a hundred percent correct
you're only incurring more risk that
something might render incorrectly I
went ahead and clicked check after
pasting my
code-in and this is good document
checking complete no errors or warnings
to show so when it comes time for pset
five and you're dabbling with HTML know
that there are tools out there this one
included and will point you at it in the
spec that just helps give you feedback
on whether something is broken so that
you can with more confidence know that
it's gonna work okay all right well
let's make something a little more
interesting now let's reimplementation
dov you know copy their HTML and use it
ourselves let's actually now make a user
interface that uses Google in some way
so Google of course in all of its forms
ultimately has a text box into which you
can type information and if I go ahead
and do this it turns out that Google is
generally going to redirect me to a
certain URL if I search for cats and hit
enter notice I got redirected to a
pretty cryptic looking URL there's a lot
of metadata in there there's a lot of
advertising information these days and
all that but it turns out and I know
this just from experience I could
distill this URL into this and it will
still work so let me go ahead and hit
enter whoops let me go ahead and hit
enter after simplifying this two
question mark Q equals cats enter and
indeed I get the same page of cats back
so what's going on so the URL itself is
not all that remarkable we've seen W W
but before you've certainly used Google
calm before this means it's secure it's
speaking HTTPS so all this now is old
hat it's not requesting index.html
because Google is dynamic the content is
constantly changing there's not some
human whose job it is to like update
Google's homepage every day with HTML so
the instead have a piece of software
running written in Python or C++ or Java
or who knows underneath the hood that is
just listening at this address so it
doesn't have to be text files that
humans created it can actually be a
program this one is called search and in
just a week or twos time YouTube will
write programs in a language called
Python that can do the same thing but
for now well let Google do the heavy
lifting and notice the question mark if
you ever see a question mark in a URL
this means to the browser here comes
some user input something that the user
probably typed into the form just like I
did cats a moment ago and then you're
gonna see something equals something
which indicates what the human typed in
now
just because Larry and Sergey some 20
years ago decided with Google comm that
this text box that we saw a moment ago
the big box that's now positioned here
they decided years ago that the name for
that text box is gonna be q4 query but
you can call it anything you want cats
is obviously what I typed in the equal
sign is just associating the two
together so this URL just means to
Google hey Google run the search program
passing in a user input name of Q whose
value shall be cats and that is how
Google knows what to search for for any
of us and frankly I can search for dogs
not even just by typing the word dogs in
here I can be a little more precise and
type it into this query because I now
know Google's URL format and voila now I
get search results for dogs instead but
that's it that's the basic building
block that's been happening all this
time and even though the URL a moment
ago was longer and uglier that was just
uninteresting detail it's not the core
business that the search is actually
providing so what does this mean I can
actually now make my own user interface
for Google by using a few new tags as
well let me go ahead and copy this as a
starting point let me go ahead and
create a new file called search dot HTML
just to save time I'll type that in
there and I'll call this search and I'm
gonna get rid of the hello body so I
just have a starting point all right
that's just the same HTML I'm copying
and pasting every time well it turns out
in HTML there is a tag called form that
will give you a form for user input and
it turns out that inside of a form you
can have different tags as well
specifically an input and inputs have
names so I can say name equals quote
unquote Q to mimic Larry and Sergey
decision years ago the founders of
Google the type of this input is text so
it's not a button or a checkbox or
something like that those exist too it's
just text and then I want a submit
button and I just know from having done
this before that I can get a submit
button by doing type equals submit and
then the value of that is gonna be
search which is the word I'm gonna see
on the screen you would only know this
by having seen it but someone else doing
it looking at someone's source code
reading an online tutorial it's not
necessarily obvious but the pattern is
the same tag name attribute equals
something attribute equals something and
so forth well now let me go ahead and
save this go into the web server and
reload the index
there's my search HTML and it's not
quite as pretty as Google's let me zoom
in so it's bigger but I do have a text
box and I have a button whose label is
search but I don't know yet where to
send it I need one more attribute or two
here it turns out that I want this form
to take the action of sending this
information to WWE google.com search the
search program on Google server but I
wanted to use that special verb we saw a
moment ago and again this was kind of
deeper in the envelope the method I
wanted to use is get in lower case in
this case so a little low level and
technical now but this just means that's
the verb you should use inside the
envelope to get the webpage but that's
it I've told the webpage and the action
you should take is submit this form to
this URL using get the method we saw
earlier submit a parameter as it's
called called q with whatever the human
typed in and then have it give us a
search button here so let me save this
go back to my page reload and now let's
go ahead and search for mice this time
and click search and voila there we have
a whole lot of mice search results but
why is the question well all I've done
is using HTML and an HTML form is I've
generated the prescribed format of a URL
calling Google's search program with a
input of Q equals mice and now as an
aside if I did take more inputs they
would be something like this something
equals value ampersand something equals
value and persons just separate these
key value pairs if you have multiple
inputs on the page but the principle is
ultimately the same so it's pretty
powerful like I've not implemented
Google per se I've implemented the front
end the user interface but in future we
can we maybe start to work on the logic
behind the scenes so any questions then
on HTTP and now that's convergence with
HTML I feel comfy with HTML because rats
are move on to another language yeah
okay so all of my examples have looked
ugly thus far except for PayPal that
looked pretty nice but I just copied and
pasted it so how do we begin to style
our websites in a more compelling way
HTML at the end of the day is mostly
used for structure of a web page just
laying out the data you care about
the words that you care about the images
that you care about but the aesthetics
that last-mile so to speak of the really
pretty colors and the right font sizes
and positioning things exactly where you
want them that is the job of another
language called CSS cascading style
sheets this tube not a programming
language it's entirely aesthetic in its
struttin its nature so let's go ahead
and take a look at an example let me go
ahead and open up the same web servers
before open up an example I saw earlier
that I made earlier called CSS zero HTML
suppose that this is the home page that
I want to create for John Harvard and
notice I've got his name big and bold at
the top and I've got a slightly smaller
font in the middle and a slightly
smaller font below it but these are just
minor font size differences it's all
centered in the page here how might I'm
actually make this this website well let
me go ahead and go into a new file here
I'll call it CSS 0 HTML let me go ahead
and paste my starting point as before
and I'll call this CSS 0 and then in the
body of this page is where I'm gonna go
ahead and lay out that content so as I
recall I had John Harvard and then below
that it was welcome to my home page
exclamation point
copyright and mmm funky symbol so I'll
just do that for now John Harvard Save
so that's CSS 0 dot HTML let me go ahead
and reload it back from my server and
voila
okay so what's wrong aesthetically it's
obviously all in one line but why how do
I fix this as before yeah yeah so I
could add the paragraph tags just to put
these all in individual paragraphs and
the IDE sometimes can be a little
annoying because now I'm going in retro
actively and adding this stuff so it's
trying to be helpful but then I have to
delete it so sometimes this autocomplete
can get in the way but it's an easy
enough fix open P let me move this over
here okay and move this over here save
go back to the browser it's not going to
change on its own I need to click reload
and now okay better it's a little ugly
more white space than I want but it's
closer certainly let's clean up that
copyright symbol turns out there's some
keys you just can't type on your
keyboard you could certainly copy/paste
it from elsewhere but hTML is in the
side
supports what are called entities and
these are numeric codes that are
sometimes written in hexadecimal
sometimes written in decimal depending
on your preference and it's just a weird
number that represents a symbol you
couldn't otherwise type watch as I
reload now to what happens to that
copyright symbol now it's the one you
might expect so minor detail it's not
all that interesting but those do exist
as well for aesthetics but this isn't
quite what I want and here's where CSS
comes in I can lay out the structure of
this page yes I have my three separate
paragraphs but they're not centered
there your font sizes are all the same
and there's be weird gaps there this is
where CSS can help so let me introduce a
few new tags instead these aren't
strictly paragraphs right it's not less
sentences and sentences of text this is
kind of like the header of my page so
let me actually rename this to header
this is maybe like the main part of my
page so let me rename this to main and
this is like the footer of my page I
would claim now it's a super simple
website but these tags exist and in the
most recent version of HTML called html5
the world has started moving away from
generic tags like P for paragraph turd
more semantic tags that are a little
more descriptive that say hey browser
here's the header of my page annoyingly
not to be confused with the head of your
page which is like the title and hey
browser here's the main part of my page
here's the footer of my page and they
will see why this is useful if only
because it describes my page a little
more compellingly but it turns out that
any HTML tag can have a style attribute
which we've not seen before and if I
want to alter the font size of this tag
I can say make this large and down here
I can say style equals font size let's
say medium and then down here I can say
style equals font size small and let me
save that go back to the browser reload
and it's not centered yet but now it's
kind of big medium and large medium and
small which is what I intended the first
time so how can I actually add centering
well turns out inside of these quotes
you can use semicolons to separate
multiple ideas if I put a semicolon here
I can now say text-align:center and let
me go ahead and copy and paste that here
and here
save and notice the pattern there's a
keyword a : and then a value a semicolon
separates it then there's a keyword a
colon and a value that's the same
pattern we're gonna see if I go back to
the browser reload now okay
now we're on our way now it looks more
like what I intended it to look like it
took a little more effort but thanks to
CSS I was able to do it so what I've
highlighted here and what the IDE is
highlighted in green is what they're
called CSS properties cascading style
sheets CSS lets you support a deal with
things like centering and font sizes and
colors and positioning and all the
aesthetics I alluded to earlier and you
just have to know what these key values
are honestly I don't know all of them
certainly I always Google when I want to
know how could I do something with this
type of tag that's because there's a lot
of online free references that just
shows you this but they all follow the
same pattern key colon value maybe
semicolon key colon value and so forth
but even if you've never written HTML
before you could probably argue that I
am NOT making designing this very well
in situ you might have found false
anytime my instinct was to copy/paste
like what is redundant in this example
yeah I'm centering all three which
honestly it just looks a little stupid
it literally was copied and pasted and
that should always rub you the wrong way
so cascading style sheets this the first
seen cascading style sheets are the only
see in cascading style sheets stands for
cascading which implies a sort of
hierarchy at two at two so let me
actually make a new example let me call
this CSS one HTML and let me paste that
same exact code but you know it occurs
to me that header and main and footer
are all children of body if you will
they're indented inside and you can you
actually can use family tree references
in the context of HTML where header is
the child of body insofar as it's inside
ever tucked indented inside of it so if
these all have the same parent so to
speak let me actually erase this from
all three tags and let me actually apply
it to the parent tag saying style equals
text-align:center
because cascading style sheets indeed
cascade so if you apply one property
like aligning in the center
to the parents it's gonna cascade down
on all of the children nested inside so
let me go ahead and save this go back to
the listing and open up CSS one HTML and
wallah no aesthetic difference but it's
just better designed right like five out
of five for design now but not
necessarily because this is a little
ugly honestly like this and we've not
had occasion to do this yet and see
because we only had one language and see
it generally is frowned upon to combine
one language like CSS with another like
HTML and they might look very similar
and they're all in the same context but
this gets annoying and especially in the
real world some people might be better
with aesthetics than others clearly from
my examples I'm not among those people
and so I might want to work with a
colleague or a friend who's much better
at design and colors and fonts than I am
and so I might want them to work
independently of me I'll work on the
structure of the webpage or if you will
my final project and let them actually
contribute more of the aesthetics so how
can we begin to decouple these things
much like and see we at least had header
files we could factor out commonalities
well it turns out we can do this a
little more differently from before let
me go ahead and open up an example to
that I made earlier called CSS to HTML
and let's scroll through this for just a
moment notice now that in the body of
this webpage I've introduced a different
tag rather a different attribute called
class so it turns out that you don't
have to just copy and paste or type out
manually all of these nitpicky font size
changes and text alignment changes you
can kind of give them more descriptive
names and arguably it's a lot more
readable to me and my partner to read
the word centered and large and medium
and small like and not see all the
stupid colons and the semicolons and the
distractions right that's like the stuff
that's not interesting when writing any
sort of code so where did these words
come from centered large medium and
small we'll notice that they're all
values of a class attribute which is
allows for customization let me scroll
up to the head of my web page and you'll
see and it's mostly white space because
I just kept hitting Enter to clean it up
notice that inside of my HTML tag is as
before my head tag if I scroll down
there's also still a title tag but
there's a new tag
alluded to earlier among the few you can
put up there called style you can factor
out to the top of your page all of the
stylizations that you care about and you
can do it as follows
notice here that I've literally written
the word centered with the dot in front
of it the word large with the dot in
front of it the word medium with the dot
small with the dot those define classes
so CSS lets you define your own
collections of configuration properties
and you can give them names just so it's
a little more descriptive and
user-friendly so you can define class
class class class and then inside the
curly braces which i've lined up here
just like in C you can have one property
two properties a hundred properties but
you can keep them nice and orderly away
from all of your HTML so that someone
else can work on them or just you can
keep the aesthetics separate from the
content of your page it's the notion of
separation of concerns keep the data
separate from the presentation there of
I so you're a library you can use that's
done this for you yes and we'll see a
little teaser for that in just a bit
so where am i using these words to be
clear here I'm saying give me a class
called centered a class called large
medium and small each of which have
these respective properties associated
with them and then down here I can just
use those words and I don't have to get
into the business of the semicolons
curly braces and all of that in my
actual HTML but it turns out I can do
this even more fancily let me open up
css3 dot HTML another example in this
case notice what I've done now my code
is really getting pretty relatively
speaking or from one person's
perspective now I don't have any
attributes right this is just tighter
like I'm using fewer characters fewer
words the fewer lines of code this is
just generally a good thing it's less
work it's less to maintain fewer
opportunities for mistakes but I've
gotten rid of it seems all of the
aesthetics but not necessarily because
CSS the second language also lets you
apply properties not to tags by way of
classes but to the actual tags
themselves so if you only have one body
it is safe to say okay CSS apply to the
body tag this or these properties hey
browser apply to the header tag this or
these proper
- the main tag the footer tag and so
forth so I don't even need to complicate
my world with small medium large and so
forth I can just apply those properties
at the top of my file to the respective
tag names whatever they are and I could
use the P tag I could use the image tag
the a tag any of those I can style them
in different ways in fact if you
wondered or started to wonder how could
you resize an image you can apply CSS to
the image tag and say make it this many
pixels or this many pixels or something
like that yeah
ah yes is it not bad designed to just
keep adding more stuff to the top and
pushing your actual content down and
down and down and just bloating the file
yes which is a wonderful segue to our
fourth and final example here which is
CSS for HTML this example let me just
zoom out that's it this CSS for dot HTML
has even fewer lines of code and indeed
no CSS in it whatsoever this is just the
website I care about the words and the
data I care about all the aesthetic
stuff well important is relegated to a
separate file that you can probably
infer it's called CSS for CSS
unfortunately and this was a stupid
design decision by humans years ago the
way you include CSS from a separate file
is paradoxically to use a link tag not
the a tag which probably should have
been called the link tag but you have a
relationship of stylesheet so sometimes
humans make poor decisions this is one
of them I would say but if you just
copy-paste and trust that this means hey
browser open up this file and use those
features from the file in this file it's
similar in spirit to C's hash include
mechanism it just looks a little
different so what's in that file well
you can probably guess if I go into CSS
for dot CSS
it's just that same content but I
factored it out as UV note wasn't the
best design to keep it all together so I
can simply put it there instead any
questions yeah
uh-huh ah good question what's a
stylesheet do in this example short
answer is that just makes clear to the
browser that the relationship between
this file CSS for dot CSS and this file
which is the HTML file is that of a
stylesheet so CSS cascading style sheets
it's a lot of words just to convey the
idea of aesthetics but that is your
stylesheet literally it's an actual file
that ends in dot CSS that should be
applied to this HTML yeah better design
why really good question so to summarize
is it isn't it wouldn't not be better
designed to have one file with your HTML
in your CSS rather than two because
things can get misplaced now they're
decoupled there's not the same inherent
link maybe honestly like that is a
reasonable concern reasonable people
will disagree generally I would say that
the programming world has decided that
separation of concerns is a good thing
so keep your HTML in one file your CSS
in another file keep them in the same
folder and frankly if you go losing your
files in a folder all the time the
problem is probably it's human problem
not a technical one but you make a good
point too and you could argue quite
credibly that you're just over
engineering this now I like it better
altogether and you'll see in cs50 s
website and Facebook and Google and
others sometimes you do see CSS together
with HTML because humans decided this
does make more sense but there are these
mechanisms in place to facilitate
collaboration to facilitate separation
so that you can keep things a little
more organized in separate files any
questions them alright so to recap where
we're at because this is a lot quickly
HTTP is this protocol via which you can
just exchange information from A to B
and B to a hTML is the language in which
web pages are written that structure the
web page and actually have your data and
CSS lets you fine-tune it now I didn't
fine-tune it all that much I just
centered it and change the font size but
honestly we can very quickly get into
the weeds of colors and positioning and
all that but that will do in sections
and in presets and in
and looking at online references that
will point you to because it just all
follows the same patterns of tags with
attributes and then CSS properties so
even though you've not seen the whole
vocabulary of CSS and HTML you have seen
the entire structure the fundamental
concepts so let's introduce then one
final piece of the puzzle and bring back
to bear some of our programming
capabilities of the past several weeks
so it turns out that in the world of
HTML and CSS you can actually introduce
a programming language as well to make
your websites even more dynamic using
something called JavaScript many of you
have taken APCs and no Java no relation
JavaScript is just a marketing decision
to them to call it something similar to
an already popular language so
javascript is a language used in
browsers typically
to give you more control over the users
experience for instance when you visit
Gmail these days and you get a new mail
it just appears magically is like a new
row in your inbox you don't have to like
reload or keep clicking refresh to see
your new mail it just appears magically
when you're using Google Maps or
something you can just click and drag
and see more of the map back in my day
you have to click a right arrow to go
this way a left arrow to go that way in
the whole webpage would actually reload
but JavaScript gives you logic and
programming capabilities in your users
Macs and PCs and phones that gets
executed not on your server but on their
browser which means you can do many more
things by running code on their
computers so what does this actually
mean well in JavaScript fortunately we
have a language that's super similar to
C but its interpreted top-to-bottom
left-to-right the browser just reads the
instructions in JavaScript and just does
them there's no compilation for you
there's no zeros and ones and so in that
sense it's just easier than C also it
has no pointers which also makes it
easier than C but it gives us the
ability to alter a web page once it's
been delivered to a user and we'll see
what we can actually do with that
capability but first let's compare and
contrast you'll recall a few weeks ago
in week 1 when we introduced C we pulled
up some scratch we pulled up some C just
to show that the ideas are still the
same let's do the same real quick here
so
we went from scratch to see let's now go
to JavaScript with variables so in C if
you wanted to set a counter to zero a la
scratch you would literally say counter
equals zero semicolon but you would have
the datatype to the left in JavaScript
the code is almost the same but you
actually don't specify datatypes you the
programmer don't worry about intz or
floats or strings or all of that you do
define the variable and the keyword to
use though there's several options that
do slightly different things is let and
the sort of thinking is let the counter
equal zero please if you will but you
don't specify the type even though
JavaScript supports numbers and strings
and so forth you just don't have to care
about them as much anymore suppose you
want to update a variable in scratch you
would just change the counter by one in
C you would do counter equals counter
plus one semicolon in JavaScript you
would do the exact same thing code is
identical in C you could also write this
more succinctly as counter plus equals
one semicolon if you recall if you don't
that's fine this is just shorthand
notation in JavaScript same exact thing
in C you could also do counter plus plus
semicolon to increment the value in
JavaScript same so this is what's nice
about JavaScript you already know much
of it just by a nature of having spent
so many weeks in the weeds with C
suppose you had a an if condition like
this is if X is less than Y and C we
would write it like this that write
JavaScript syntax is the same if you had
an if-else syntax is the same if else if
else syntax is the same if you want a
forever loop syntax is the same while
true if you want a for loop syntax is
almost the same let needs to be used
instead so this is C because it says int
I equals 0 and so forth that's a data
type JavaScript I just claimed doesn't
worry for you don't need to worry about
those data types so in JavaScript you
would instead say let's instead but
otherwise the syntax is the same so
that's a nice starting point because
there's nothing like new to learn
syntactically we just need to apply the
same logic that we saw in week 0 in one
sense to HTML so if this is a
representative webpage albeit super
simple this is the one I brought up
earlier how
we now start thinking about this webpage
in a way that is conducive to
programming it and actually changing it
dynamically well let me propose that you
think of this same webpage it's just a
tree and we introduce trees just a week
ago I'll be it in the context of C and
frankly and C they're a headache because
you have to wire things together using
pointers and nodes and all of that don't
worry about that now
it's the browser's job to build this in
memory or RAM for you and indeed when I
keep saying that a browser upon
receiving an envelope with HTML reads it
top to bottom left to right
I haven't said what it does with it what
it essentially does with is is it
creates this data structure in memory
for you and it is chrome or edge or
Firefox or whatever browser you're using
that itself is written and probably C or
C++ or some other language some other
human at those companies wrote the code
that builds all of the pointers and or
whatever is used to build this structure
in memory but this is what the browser
has in mind once it's read your HTML and
now that it's a data structure in memory
you can make changes to it just like
last week we were inserting humans into
our linked list changing the data
structure the browser can add more nodes
or more tags to the page dynamically so
if you kind of run with this in your
mind when you get a new email in Gmail
what is happening well the web page when
you first load it in Gmail has a whole
bunch of TD tags probably your TR tags
rather for table row table row table row
each of which represents an email
perhaps when you get a new email the
browser is probably just adding another
TR node to this tree because notice the
words here HTML lines up with this tag
head lines up with this tag body lines
up with this tag so it stands to reason
that when you get another row in your
inbox with another email someone is just
adding a node to that tree and that
someone is JavaScript the language in
which you can control the user's browser
even after they've loaded your web page
for the first time so what can we
actually do with this let's start simple
as follows let me go ahead and just whip
up really quickly a file called hello
zero dot HTML and we'll do it as before
with our doctype HTML
my HTML tag here my head tag here my
title here will be hello zero and notice
I've been moving these two separate
lines you don't strictly need to do that
just to keep the hierarchy the
whitespace again doesn't matter but I'll
be consistent there and in my body here
I'll say this time just hello world by
default so that's a pretty simple web
page as well let's actually now make it
interactive all of my web pages thus far
had been static content except for the
Google one but even that wasn't so much
interactive as it was the moment I hit
submit it it made the problem Google's
problem to deal with let's keep the user
with me this time let me go ahead and do
this let me get rid of this form here
let me create a new file now called
hello one that's my next version and let
me go ahead and paste that same code but
this time let me have the browser be a
little interactive let me go ahead and
have a form here because what I want is
a text box type equals text I'm not
gonna bother giving it a name yet and
then you have another one called type
equals submit save let me go ahead and
open up my server so I can see this file
this I said was what hello one dot HTML
okay so it's just a simple form but
there's no connection to Google this
time let me start to use this form
interactively because if I have the
ability to program I bet I could take
the user's input and do something with
it so how do I do this well let me
propose first that I want the human to
type their name into this form and then
when they click Submit I want it to say
hello David or hello Veronica hello
Bryan whatever the name actually is like
some of our see examples so you know
what let me let me write that function
first it turns out that in the head of
your web page you can have not just the
title and not just style but also a tag
called script for JavaScript for
instance and in this tag I can actually
write code and there's something a
little different in JavaScript instead
of writing like void greet as the name
of my function and then writing the body
of my function here and then saying void
here for instance Java scripts a little
looser if you don't want to take any
arguments just don't mention them no
mention a void if you don't have a
return and actually don't even mention a
return type just call it a function so
slight difference from C it's a little
lazier you don't
about input types you don't worry about
output types you just say give me a
function called greet well what do I
want this function to do turns out in
JavaScript there's a function called
alert that's just gonna pop up a window
that says something in it and I can pass
as an argument to this JavaScript
function whatever it is I want it to say
so let's go ahead and say hello comma
world semicolon all right it's almost
identical to C again except that I'm
saying function instead of a return type
and alert apparently exists and there's
no sharp include or any of that that we
typically had in C it's just literally
in my browser right now so let me go
ahead and save that and go down to the
form tag here and it turns out on the
form tag there's a special attribute
called on submit and as the word implies
it says when the form is submitted
on the submission of this form go ahead
and execute this greet so I can actually
tell the browser on submission of this
form to call a function that I wrote and
now let me just preemptively write
return false for reasons we'll come back
to in a moment just to make sure this
actually works now let me go ahead and
save this go to hello one HTML open that
up and let me just change the title for
consistency okay so hello one dot HTML
and let me go ahead and say David submit
hello world all right not really sure
what the point of typing my name was but
it at least seems to work as programmed
but obviously where I'm going with this
is I want to pro I want to participate
my name so when the human has typed in
their name to the box and click Submit
that's triggering a submission of the
form but wait when the form is submitted
I'm calling greet so it sounds like it's
greets job to figure out what the word
is that the human typed in so how can I
do this it's a little cryptic and this
is where now it becomes JavaScript
specific and not C let me go ahead and
define a variable called name and let me
use this fancy technique document dot
query selector and then in here I'm
gonna need to specify what node in the
tree I want to select so I'm actually
getting ahead of myself let's look at
the HTML at the moment I've got a form
tag and two input
neither of which has a name and I could
fix that but let me actually do a
different technique HTML also supports
unique identifiers and you can give them
literally that unique IDs you can call
it whatever you want foo bar Baz XYZ I'm
gonna make it more descriptive and call
it ID equals name because what I can now
do up here in query selector is actually
specify what it is I want to select from
the nut from the tree that tree is
called a Dom or document object model
verbose lis and I need to want do one
last thing turns out and you would only
know this from experience that if name
is the unique identifier of an element
and not the name of a tag I actually
need to prefix it with a hash unrelated
to C's hash but otherwise this function
query selector is going to think that
there's a tag called name so this means
on ID whose value is named alright it's
a bit of a mouthful but here we go
once I select that node from the tree I
want to get its value and set it I want
to get its value
semicolon okay what is going on first
recall from this tree here that whenever
the browser loads HTML it has some HTML
it builds a tree structure there in each
of those nodes is selectable via this
function called query selector what is
document well it turns out in JavaScript
there's this special global variable
called document that refers to the whole
document the whole webpage built into
that as a function called query selector
that is that dot notation is reminiscent
of C's struct syntax so you can think of
document as a struct that represents the
whole page inside of it is a function
not just data but a function called
query selector you're gonna see this all
over the place in JavaScript dots
because people the JavaScript world is
much more voluminous than C so there's
lots of functions inside of other
containers or structures alright so with
that said this is just saying hey
browser let me have a variable called
name and store the value of the node
that has a unique identifier of name and
get that by using this function select
it that like grabs the rectangle from
the picture and gives me access to the
value that the human typed in now I'm
not done with this I
to actually display that value and it's
not going to be correct to do this
otherwise I'm just going to see hello
name so there is not this convention
which we had in C there's another way to
do this but I'm going to go ahead and do
it as follows I'm just gonna use
concatenation so this is not possible in
C but in JavaScript if you have a string
on the left and a string on the right
using plus will not add them together
which would make no sense it will
concatenate them like glue one to the
other in see how would you do this it is
an utter nightmare right like in C how
would you do this this would be an array
of characters on the left that has a
null character at the end this would be
another array of characters on the right
with a null character at the end neither
is big enough to fit the other as well
so you'd have to allocate a new array of
characters copy these in get rid of the
backslash 0 copy these and keep the
backslash 0 throw those away and then
you have concatenated strings that is so
many damn steps in C and this is why no
one likes programming in C and you don't
have to do it anymore in JavaScript just
use the plus operator that does all of
that for you but hopefully you do have
an underlying appreciation of what the
plus operator is actually doing
underneath the hood because the computer
is still doing the same work the
difference is this week onward we the
human do less of that work ourselves so
plus is an abstraction for all of that
complexity so if I didn't mess this up
let me go ahead and save now I'll go to
the browser reload and type in my name
David submit and there we have it
hello David let's do one more test we'll
try say Veronica submit and voila you'll
notice that it's trying to be helpful
now my browser like if I start D then it
sees autocomplete or V well it forgot
about Veronica apparently Veronica let's
see if we reload V that's weird
don't tell Veronica Chrome doesn't
remember her but we can turn that
feature off is the point by actually
doing things like this even you would
know this from the online manual
autocomplete equals off turns off that
feature auto focus also does something
handy if you've ever been to a webpage
and you can just start typing Chrome and
Mac OS highlights it in blue that just
means give focus like
put the cursor there if you don't have
that the webpage starts like this and
we've all visited websites and I think
like my dog Harvard's among them we have
to stupidly click there just to start
interacting with the page that is not
necessary that's bad programming just
using the right tags can fix that kind
of thing questions what if we have two
IDs with the same name you should not
that is human error an ID by definition
must be unique and if you have two by
the same name the human messed up and
what it does I don't know what the
behavior is it's probably unofficially
not documented or maybe you picked the
first maybe it picks the last I don't
know but you shouldn't rely on it anyway
good question good corner case other
questions all right let me let me jump
ahead to one example and then we'll come
back to a fancier version of this let me
open up a program that's in today's
source 5 directory called background
HTML it's got some familiar act letters
which probably stand for red green blue
probably these are three buttons and
we've seen buttons we've saw the search
button and the submit buttons that I've
created before but using JavaScript I
can do kind of fun things like this if I
click on our whoo the web page just
changed G be RGB this is now interactive
right if you were just writing HTML and
CSS you'd have to pick one of those
colors and stick with it but with
JavaScript you can respond and that's
because a browser has lots and lots of
events happening all the time events
include clicks or Mouse's movement mice
moving or dragging or in a mobile device
touching so there's lots of things that
a human can be doing with a web browser
and you can write code that responds to
all of those kinds of events and so let
me actually go ahead and open up
background HTML and show how this is
working so for the most part it's just
HTML at first here's the HTML tag the
head tag the body tag and three new tags
this is another way of creating buttons
and begin this isn't interesting you
learn this in the online reference or
manual and it just tells you here's how
to use a button it follows the same
paradigm tag name attribute equals value
the label is just going to be our G and
B and now this is where things get a
little scary looking at first but that's
it
there's just lines of code here inside
of the webpage now let's walk through
this line by line even though it's a
little verbose at first so this first
line here says hey browser give me a
variable called body and store in that
variable the node the rectangle so to
speak that has the name body so that is
pluck that rectangle out of the picture
so that I have direct access to it why
because I'm gonna manipulate it in just
a moment this is the scariest the
JavaScript will look for now document
dot query selector cache read could
someone translate that into just English
what's that doing for me yep being a
little more verbose someone else hey
browser select for me the node whose
unique ID is read that's fine like give
me access to that node the state of the
structure in memory and this is where
it's a little weird so it turns out that
every tag in a web page or node in a
tree the Dom tree so to speak document
object model can have event listeners
associated with it and you would only
know this from the documentation but if
you literally say go into this structure
this node that represents the red button
and get its on click value what's cool
with JavaScript even though the syntax
is a little scary-looking is you can
associate a function with that event so
this is saying hey browser when the red
button is clicked on call the following
function and what's new and JavaScript
here is that this function at the moment
has no name which is weird you could
technically do this in C but we always
gave our functions names but you don't
really need to give a function a name if
you don't need to mention it ever again
and the detail that's happening here for
us is this this says hey browser on
click call this function what does that
mean in real terms hey browser call all
of the lines of code in between this
open curly brace and this close curly
brace so even if you're not comfy with
the syntax it just literally means
execute the following lines of code when
this button is clicked this is what's
known as an anonymous function insofar
as it has no name it's just function
open
closed paren so you can probably infer
what it's doing on this line here let me
highlight this line in blue it's a
little cryptic and again I kind of
promise that you're gonna see lots of
these dots but this is saying hey
browser modify the body or specifically
the style of the body and specifically
the background color of the style of the
body to be of course red and the rest of
the code is copy paste for now for green
and blue as well so what is happening
every time you click on one of those
buttons are or G or B literally this
line of code is getting executed that
I've just highlighted or this line of
code is getting executed or this line of
code is getting executed so even though
the syntax is yes admittedly way more
complicated than we've seen thus far the
idea is relatively simple select the
button tell it on clicking to call this
function and it's fine or lian if you
just copy and paste this and for pset
five you won't have to use any of this
code this is in preemptive look at what
you can do with an eye toward fancier
features like final projects and beyond
any questions then on this background
example yeah
ah good question why don't we use the
pound symbol for red green and blue but
not for body if you look at the HTML
you'll see the following body is
apparently the name of a tag so that's
why we just selected body with that line
of code down here
however red green and blue are not the
names of tags they are the unique
identifier values that I just came up
with I could have called it XYZ but I
chose more descriptive terms so whenever
you want to reference or select a node
who that has an identifier you use the
hash instead that's all these are just
human conventions that are non obvious
unless you were told what they all mean
all right let's try one other example
with JavaScript it's not uncommon on
like news websites to have the ability
to change the font size which you can
actually do on your Mac and PCs
sometimes using keyboard shortcuts but
sometimes it's built into the webpage
itself let me go into for instance size
dot HTML and here's some Latin text or
Latin like text and notice that it has a
little select menu normally when you
have a select menu you select something
and then you click Submit and then the
server deals with it like the
information goes somewhere but you don't
need to do that you can actually make
little menus interactive just like text
boxes suppose I want to make this text a
little smaller I can do that I can
choose extra small I can do extra extra
small or I can do extra extra large and
so what's going on here well just like
there are click events in a browser
there are also change events or
selection events just anything that can
happen on the web page you can listen
for so let's take a look at this code
for instance we've not seen this tag
before but we have seen paragraph and
there's a paragraph of Latin and then
there's a select tag which gives you a
select menu a drop-down menu is called
the Select menu in HTML and here's how
you have all the options now there is a
bit of duality here there's what the
human sees which is between the open tag
and closed tag and then there's this
value which the computer sees but more
on that another time when we get to
python but this just gives me that whole
menu of size options and if i scroll
down now notice i have a script tag down
here and in this script tag I have
document query selector quote-unquote
select because I want to select the name
the tag that hey whose name is select
and then there's this event on change
and you only know this from the
documentation but like on submit on
change is called any time you change
that menu what function should
called well this one here which is an
anonymous in the sense that it has no
name and go ahead and do this select
from the document the body tag get
access to its style and change its font
size to and this is funky here this dot
value so what did I do here let me do
this no pun intended this refers to
whatever element in the webpage induced
this function to be called so this is
you can think of as a variable a special
variable that always refers to whatever
element you are listening to and so this
dot value just saves me some keystrokes
because I don't you need to use document
dot query selector to get at this select
menu but we'll see this again perhaps
down the road questions and let me point
out one thing that's stupid
this here font size looks different from
CSS in CSS what did we call this do you
remember we did font size like small
medium large
it was font size okay so this was sort
of left hand not talking to right hand
when these things were invented it turns
out that - in JavaScript means what
maybe - or subtraction and so this
syntax just breaks in the context of
JavaScript so what did humans do they
decided that any time you have a CSS
property that's word - something get rid
of the - capitalize the next word and
that's now the mapping in JavaScript so
just a simple heuristic there that you
can perhaps keep in mind let's take a
look perhaps in one final value oh how
about two final values let's go ahead
and do this with blink HTML so back in
the day when the web was first being
invented in HTML was in its infancy
there was a wonderful tag that was
probably on my own personal homepage
called blink that literally did that you
could have a tag that was open bracket
bli NK close bracket put some words then
close the tag and your webpage would
just do this to all visitors which
humans eventually realized well this is
dumb
really annoying to look at bad user
experience or UX but with job and so
they took it away it's like one of the
few tags I think from HTML that was
actually removed by committee as opposed
to added there was also Mark II at the
time too that like a like a theater
signed with just scroll words across
your page so you've probably seen
websites like this that recreate them in
some way but you can do this with
JavaScript right think about this
logically code we know how in code we
can change the style of an element we've
not seen how to do this yet but you can
make us an element show or hide show or
hi turns out in JavaScript you can use a
timer you have access to a clock and you
could actually write code that says you
know what every half-second call this
function call this function call this
function call this function what that
function does is it changes the style of
the page to hide or show hide or show
now this used to be built into browsers
but now you can recreate it with
something like that and I'll wave my
hand at what the code is but that's just
one feature there let's look at one
final example though that's a little
creepy here's the code first and this is
called geolocation
right this is all the rage now with apps
like uber and ways and find my friends
on iphone and the like here is
relatively little code that will figure
out where your user is in the world now
it's a bit of a mouthful here but it's
mostly this file HTML with a script tag
but there's this other special global
variable and we won't use this much and
indeed you might not ever use it if you
don't care about this feature but it's
called navigator for historical reasons
and navigator has a feature called
geolocation and geolocation which stands
for locate people geographically has a
function called get current position and
for reasons we won't really get into it
takes a function as an argument this is
a very common JavaScript paradigm but
more on this toward final projects
perhaps this line of code is going to
write to the document the users latitude
and if we scroll to the right their
longitude so this is where it gets
creepy so if you were to use this code
in your website and a user were to visit
like I will now and they click the link
they will be prompted do you want the
website to know your location sometimes
you might say yes sometimes you might
say no frankly most of us probably just
click allow instinctively without really
thinking about this but there's where I
am a pair
let me go ahead and highlight that let
me go to maps.google.com because
whatever website you just visited
whether it's Facebook or CNN or a lot of
news websites want to know where you are
if you go to like what fandango.com or
the like for movie tickets they might
want to know where you are well you're
giving them very precise information if
I go ahead and search for these GPS
coordinates on Google that's not where I
am what the hell why are we in Oklahoma
I don't understand what's going on
let's okay this was not part of the
demonstration this was going to be the
big climax let's turn off the wired
internet in here and apparently we're
going through Oklahoma today let's turn
on the Wi-Fi which will just give me a
different IP address which is a
wonderful way to tie the start of the
lecture together if I wait a second it
should go green come on no IP address
now these words might make a little more
sense come on give me an IP address come
on Harvard University
okay we'll email the IT people about
this later but all of my internet I mean
what this means is my no this is really
weird okay we have a lot of footage to
cut out of today's video so what this
does is with low probability tell you
where your users are in terms of
latitude and longitude so that you could
geo locate them figure out what the
local movie theaters are or what the
starting times of stores are give them
directions to places and the like and
while that was supposed to be the big
climactic finish apparently none of this
works today was completely wrong we're
in Oklahoma but let's end here today
I'll stick around for questions we'll
see you next time